كثير من المواقع وتعرف احنا في السوشيال
ميديا الان الكل يفتي والكل يعني يبدع حتى
في موضوع الهلال الكل يصمم ويضع ويخترع
وتتناقله الركبان
اشيع من سنوات تقريبا
ان من قام بتصميم العلم هو مستشار الملك
عبد العزيز الشيخ حافظ وهبه المعلومه هذه
غير موجوده ابدا هناك تكليف من المغفور
لها الملك المؤسس الملك عبد العزيز طيب
الله ثراه في عام 1937 حينما كلف
الهيئه الاستشاريه او قبل هذا التاريخ في
عام 26 26 ميلادي
1926,344 يعني من مئه سنه تقريبا كلف
الهيئه الاستشاريه في مناسبه البيعه ان
يقوموا والمكون من عدد المستشاري
والمندوبين ان يقوموا بعمل وتصميم شكل
العلم والعمله السعوديه ولكن اذا ظهرت على
شكل الحالي ولكن
حقيقه امر انه الشيخ حافظ وهبه هو من صمم
هلا هذا العلم اعتقد لا يوجد لها مصدر